euh Marion marichchal quand vous avez
appris samedi soir cet attentat vous
avez réagi comment mais je en fait je
sais plus on arrive plus à savoir si on
est sidéré triste en colère moi j'ai une
forme de révolte he je vais pas vous
mentir parce que là je en arrivant chez
vous j'ai refait la liste un peu de tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui avaiit commis des
attentats il y a eu 56 attentats depuis
2012 donc c'est assez phénoménal ce qui
étaient fichés c'est exactement comme
vous vouz le dire c'est qui était
identifié par l'État et suivi par l'État
pour radicalisation islamiste je vais
vous faire un petit rappel parce que
c'est quand même assez terrifiant
l'attentat du Talis en 2015 fiché s le
massacre du Battle clan 2015 l'un d'eux
était fiché s l'assassinat du pèreamel
il était fiché s la tentative d'attentat
sur les champsélysée c'est fich s le
terrorisme de l'Opéra fiché s l'attentat
du marché de Noël à Strasbourg fich s le
le l'assassinat Dominique Bernard fich s
l'attentat aujourd'hui donc à la Tour
Effel fich S et là j'ai c'est non
exorciif donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
où on a un état et vous avez raison de
le rappeler avec des forceces de l'ORD
des de renseignement qui font leur
travail qui identifient des gens qui les
suivent et pour autant on voit bien que
ces gens restent en liberté et donc moi
la conclusion à laquelle j'arrive c'est
justement vous AZ faire votre
proposition oui aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
qu'on a 5000 vous l'avez rappelé 5000
personnes qui sont parmi les plus
dangereux donc fichers pour islamisme
qui menace la vie 76 millions de
Français on a l'impression qu'on doit
attendre chaque jour qu'ils assassinent
ou égorge des enfants des adolescents ou
ou ou des adultes ou des touristes ou
des profs ou des jeunes filles pour
réagir et donc il me semble puisqu'il
existe un principe de précaution pour
l'environnement il a existtit un
principe de précaution pour le covid où
là personne n'a rien trouvé à redire
pour enfermer l'intégralité de la
population chez elle qu'il faut avoir un
principe de précaution vis-à-vis de ces
bombes à retardement identifié comme tel
et suivi pour cela c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut une arrestation immédiate et une
détention préventive de tous les
fichiers s aujourd'hui en France pour
les neutraliser et neutraliser leur
dangerosité le temps d'étudier au cas
par cas chacune des situations
neutraliser comment comment vous
c'està-dire il faut les mettre en centre
de rétention en détention provisoire
est-ce qu'on a les place avant le
passage à l'acte mais il faut qu'on les
ait faut qu' je veux dire momenté ça
devrait priorité de l'État l'État
devrait penser à ça matin midi et soir
Marion marichchal 5000 places
aujourd'hui euh en prison ou en en
préventive centre de rétention centre de
rétention on les pas si l'État est
capable aujourd'hui de répartir sur
l'ensemble du territoire des dizaines de
milliers de mineurs isolés ou de
migrants je pense qu'il est capable
aujourd'hui de réquisitionner des lieux
pour pouvoir en urgence mettre ces
personnes dans des centres de posons la
question aux téléspectateurs
oualiser le temps une fois de plus qu'il
soit étudié au cas par cas parce que
soit ce sont des étrangers légaux et ou
des clandestins et dans ce ils doivent
être expulsés mais les délais
d'expulsion sont tellement longs que le
temps que ce soit traité ils sont des
menaces soit ce sont des binationaux et
dans ce cas c'est le cas notamment
d'ailleurs de de celui qui a frappé
samedi dernier ils doivent être déchus
de leur nationalité française et
également expulsé mais tout ça prend du
temps donc le temps une fois de plus que
les procédures aboutissent il doivent
être mis hors d'état de nuire et soit
ils sont français et dans ce cas-là il
faut donner le temps d'aller voir dans
ses profils et dans leur environnement
ce qui peut entraîner des condamnations
pour ensuite les les protéger le citoyen
alors Mar Mario mar juste on a
l'impression que là ça s'accélère de
plus en plus à chaque fois qu'il y a un
drame c'est un fichier s c'est vrai on a
l'impression que en fait c'est fichers S
c'est c'est quoi on a l'impression que
fichers S c'est juste avant de commettre
un DRAM on est fich S et vous vous avez
raison parce que faut regarder le genre
de profil qui se balade aujourd'hui et
qui sont fichers s je regardais tout à
l'heure là le 6 octobre dernier il y a
l'avocat THB de Montbrial je sais pas si
vous voyez qui est un avocat médiatique
connu et engagé dans la lutte justement
contre l'islamisme il a été menacé au
cours d'une instance de décapitation par
un fichier s qui est bien connu alors là
j'ai son CV c'est quand même assez
édifiant donc le type a été six fois
signalisé à la justice il a contribué à
la radicalisation du co-assassin des
policiers de maganville il a été
interpellé en route vers un camp
d'entraînement pour devenir djihadiste
il a été condamné d'ailleurs par le
passé pour des faits lié au terrorisme
et aujourd'hui cet homme il travaille il
est libre il touche les APL voilà donc
voilà le genre de profil aujourd'hui qui
est dans la nature et donc ce genre de
profil ne doit pas être dans la nature
il doit être en déttionir ce qu'on fait
deose à nos téléspectateurs et là et ce
que vous proposez c'est donc tous les
fichers donc les 5000 fichers les mettre
dans un centre de de détention de
rétention pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous l'AZ rappelé
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on dit on peut
pas mettre un policier derrière chacun
d'eux aujourd'hui il y a 5000 fichiers s
aujourd'hui il y a un peu plus de 4500
personnes de la DGSI donc qui ne sont
pas en mesure matérielle humaine de
pouvoir suivre 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7 ces personnes un syndicat
j'ai vu ça dans Le Parisien témoignage
de syndicat de policier qui disait que
si on voulait suivre efficacement ces
personnes il faudrait qu'il a entre 10
et 12 policiers par personne fich est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord ou pas avec la
proposition
oui oui non s'il vous plaît oui non oui
nonou non oui Daniel oui oui ben non non
parce que pour la simple et bonne raison
que vous savez que c'est pas pas
faisable en tout cas en l'état des
chos faut pas dire que c'est pas fais
cette proposition a déjà été faite en
a F soit pas cons les Français vous
croyez qu'ils veulent sentendre c'est
pas
constitutionnel comment c'est une vraie
questionimportant de rappeler que la
détention préventive elle existe dans
plusieurs cas elle existe dans la
rétention de sûreté après une
condamnation elle existe par exemple
dans l'hospitalisation du d'office
justement sur le cas psychiatrique elle
existe dans la signation à résidence
donc elle existe aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de cas à partir du moment
où il y a un contrôle du juge et ce que
reproche le Conseil d'État à l'époque
c'est dans la proposition qui a été qu'
N a pas de contrôle du juge donc
contrôle du juge des libertés qui puisse
en effet régulièrement réévaluer la
situation croyez que le le le jeune
Allemand là qui est mort là samedi soir
on va lui dire le Conseil
constitutionnel ne veut pas raisonner à
droit constant c'est non mais mais je
vais vous dire aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
il faut qu'il y a des choses qui change
on part du principe qu'il y a des drames
qui s'accumulent de semaine en semaine
on a vu fich s fich s fich s fich s à un
moment c'est on prend des décisions ou
bien on continue comme ça et on va tous
les toutes les semaines on va recevoir
Mar maréchal on va recevoir quel
quelqu'un voilà de reconquête on va
recevoir quelqu'un voilà de de T les de
tous les partis toutes les semaines vont
dire oui c'est vrai que c'est dramatique
mais bon ça aurait pas pu être évité et
cetera les gars un moment c'est où on
prend des décisions et on évite les
drames ou bien on dit rien et on dit bah
non on peut pas parce que il y a si on
peut pas parce qu'il y a ça Gilles
Verdes qui a toujours réponse à tout et
qui est quand même le ben non mais c'est
vrai vous êtes quand même le grand REM
de l'émission comme on dit ici quelle
est votre solution puis que vous avez
toujours des solutions à tout mais vous
ne faites jamais rien non mais je vais
d'abord répondre à Madame Marion
maréchal votre proposition elle est
complètement délirante excusez-moi les
fich s les fichers s ce ne sont pas des
gens dont la dangerosité est établ vous
savez très
bien pas Mo sén ministère deintérieur
des rign sur des gens don
certainil
don des très je la différence re vous je
vais pas attendre qu'il passe à l'il pas
attendre de protéger des gens qui AUD
radicalis dangereux islamistes de savoir
si demain ils vont aller égorger
quelqu'un donc toi tu vas mettre toi tu
vas mettre un policier derrière les 5000
fich 12 policiers derrièreè derrière les
5000 mais c'est quoi ta solution toi de
il avait été en prison parce qu'il
projetait un attentat à la défense très
bien mais des gens des gens qui n'ont
pas projeté d'attentat à titre préventif
simplement sur ce qu'ils sont et parce
que ils sont
prochesam on va pas les mettre en
prentation par
a que 5000 fich c'est
pasorme donc tout enlève l'appellation F
qui sert à rien et c'est n'importe quoi
c'est comme au qtf et les mecs qui sont
toujours là enlever les appellations à
ce momentl les 5000 personnes c'est pas
des F par exemple à la rétention de
sûreté vous savez la rétention de sûreté
c'est la prolongation donc d'une
décision de justice enfin du maintien en
détention à l'issue d'une condamnation
parce que il y a des profils dangereux
est-ce que vous êtes opposé à du toutis
très favorable parce que la
R
sauf que c'est en dehors de la peine
c'est de la détention préventive parce
que les personnes restent dangereuses la
condamnation a été faite ça veut dire
qu'on est hors du cadre judiciaire on
est dans la c'est la même logique sauf
que là c'est avant la commission d'un
Act le temps de pouvoir savoir ce qu'
fait de une FO plus Madame C gens ét
condamnés là vous parlez de mettre en
prison des gens qui n'ont
potentiellement rien fait qu'est-ce que
tu racontes que tu fais toi alors
qu'est-ce que tu fais toi le le tolier
là mais mais moi je suis pas ministre
l'intérieur ren oui B oui exuse-mi moi
je maximise le renseignement je fais à
fond rign et tu vois pas qu'ils sont ils
sont top du renseignement dis pas de
bêtis et je et je relance ce seur
finistr qui la psychiatrie
parce répondre je voudrais dire deux
choses qui me semblent importante la
première c'est que l'individu dont on
parle il y a 2 ans les policiers de la
DGSI avaient demandé à une juge de
pouvoir faire une visite domiciliaire et
ça a été refusé par le magistrat je
d'accord vous ça c'est le premier point
et le deuxième point ce qui est très
compliqué dans ces affaires là c'est que
il y a pas de logistique criminelle il y
a un couteau un marteau donc même si on
fait une visite domiciliaire qu'on
trouve un couteau un marteau pas vous
êtes d'accord vous êtes d'accord avec sa
proposition le profil vous l'avez quand
même rappelé tout à l'heure il y a quand
même des signes qui vont au-delà de la
détention d'armes ça veut dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui suivi dans les et sa mère
l'avait signalé donc et l'attentat avait
été projeté c'està-dire qu'il en avait
parlé il y a un mois y a des gens sur
Twitter qui disent alors c'est dur ce
qu'il disent ils disent il faudrait
parfois on pense à un Guantanamo à la
française mais personne n'aura le
courage de le faire Guantanamo non mais
oui un Guantanamo c'est dire en fait ils
veulent que ces gens soient mis derrière
les barreaux hors d'état de nuire le
temps de
savoir et moi je je l'entends mais là on
parle de rétention administrative mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui à
situation exceptionnelle réponse
exceptionnelle ça veut dire qu'on ne
peut pas continuer d'attendre que des
gens identifi comme dangereux une fois
de plus passe à l'acte regardez les
profils à chaque fois parce que cet
Hommel avait déjà été condamné en plus
par le passé parce qu'on dit oui disiez
il avait pas étéé il a été condamné il a
fait 6 ans et quand on connaît l'état de
notre justice il a dû aller loin parce
que avant de faire 6 ans de prison ferme
dans notre pays faut quand même y aller
ex si en trison ferme c'est beaucoup
juste vous vous êtes vous êtes pourquoi
moi je suis d'accord d'abord pour
étudier et les mettre hors d'état de
nuire pendant quelqu pendant le temps
qu'on étudie mais je suis aussi d'accord
sur certains cas avec un en fait il il y
a des gens qui ne se déradicaliseront
jamais et quand ce qu'on a très très peu
dit et ce que j'ai lu mais j'en croyais
pas mes yeux c'est que cette personne
qui a été condamnée là 4 ans en 2019 un
an avant sa libération il y avait trois
personnes qui étaient ils étaient
obligés d'être trois pour rentrer dans
sa cellule tellement il était dangereux
avec un un des gilets par lâ il avait
menacé d'égorger ses parents à sa sortie
et c'est ça c'est quelques mois avant
qu'on le laisse sortir et on le laisse
sortir ensuite et et il fait ce qu'il a
ce qu'il a fait donc il y a là il y a
plein de radicalisés qui vont sortir qui
ont fait 5 7 ans de prison dans les
années 201526 dangereux donc oui donc ça
c'est un premier pas mais moi j'iris
même encor plus lo in il y en a qu'on ne
pourra pas déradicaliser et qui seront
des dangers à vie celui-ci il nous a
joué pendant quelques temps je suis
encore en contact avec des des
radicalisés mais c'est pour les
combattre c'était du pipo donc
excusez-moi il y en a on ne pourra pas
sera des Dang avec vous mais imaginez
quand même que l'un des deux assassins
du père amamel était sous bracelet
électronique donc on voit bien qu'en
fait il y a pas d'autres solutions à
leur actuel que en effet les empêcher de
sortir et de se balader librement
maintenant moi je suis d'accord avec
vous je pense que derrière parce que ce
qui est intéressant c'est quand même
qu'on avait de quoi le condamner sur un
certain nombre de choses notamment de
l'apologie du terrorisme et ça n'a pas
été fait parce qu'en fait le suivi est
tellement difficile aujourd'hui
qu'onarrive pas et on n pas le temps de
pouvoir capter ces gens et savoir quelle
réponse apporter mais vous avez raison
c'est là où on se troupe en voulant
psychanalyser ou psychatriser
systématiquement les cas je je lisais
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs un expert des
questions djihadistes j'ai son nom
m'échappe il est professeur ass Micheron
monsieur Micheron Hugo Micheron qui
disait attention à la psychiatrisation
des cas parce que aujourd'hui on on est
face à une idéologie on n'est pas face à
une maladie mentale et on est dans une
société on a du mal à penser le mal on
pense que la personne qui tue
mécaniquement est un dingue de fait il
est manifestement déséquilibré mais je
pense que c'est une erreur et on n'ura
pas une seulement une réponse médicale
le sondage on va avoir Jacques cardos
qui fait partie des noms lui des 6,8 %
qui disent non qui sont pas d'accord
avec votre proposition 93 % nos
téléspectateurs sont d'accord avec la
proposition de Marion maréchal alors moi
je vais vous dire votre Conseil
constitutionnel et vos trucs là et c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible on parle
pas de ça les gars moi j'en ai marre
d'entendre des gens ici qui sont des
bons suiveurs et qui disent ça c'est pas
possible ça c'est pas possible elle est
pas là pour dire ça ce soir elle est pas
là pour dire c'est pas possible elle est
en train de dire on va essayer de faire
ça et on va faire tout tout ce qui tout
ce qu'on peut pour faire évoluer les
lois les gars donc c'est pas la peine de
me dire et le Conseil constitutionnel va
retoquer et ma mère elle va dire que
c'est pas bien je m'en tape de ça je
vous le dis je m'en tape parce que c'est
où on avance exactement si on fait
avancer les choses et le le garde des
saut prend des décisions c'est rapide
pour faire évoluer les lois et surtout
dans ce sens quand il voit un sondage
comme ça il y a pas c'est pas des fous
qui nous regardent c'est des Français
nous on représente toute la France en
plus hein je vous le dis sur un sonage
comme ça 93 % des gens c'est un
plébiscite sur C regardez voyez voyez ou
pas plébisite